[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL DREZNER: Thank you.
Thank you all for coming.
It's good to be back
to the Bay Area.
The one problem with
getting a PhD from a place
usually is that they don't hire
you afterwards as a professor.
So you're sort of
like Moses knowing
that when you get
to the promised land
you can't go inside the walls.
So it's good occasionally
to visit and know
that you can be back.
So this book is a
little personal for me
in the sense of
one of the reasons
I got a PhD in political science
was that I sort of naively
believed that part
of what you could do
would be to influence
the marketplace of ideas.
That as a political scientist
I could write things
in a variety of venues and
people would read them.
And who knows, maybe policy
would actually get changed.
And to be fair, that's not
entirely unrealistic or I
wasn't--
I didn't think it was
necessarily naive.
John Maynard Keynes in one
of his great masterworks
wrote very famously
"The ideas of economists
and political philosophers,
both when they are right
and when they are wrong, are
more powerful than is commonly
understood.
Indeed the world is
ruled by little else.
Practical men who
believe themselves
to be quite exempt from
any intellectual influence
are usually the slaves of
some defunct economist,
mad men in authority who
hear voices in the air
are distilling the frenzy
from some academic scribbler
of a few years back."
So Keynes thinks
that ideas matters--
I'm not nearly as smart as
he is-- but I thought maybe
that would potentially be the
way in which you could actually
have an impact on the world.
And there is that
kind of naive view
that even if you write less
sort of serious scholarly work,
eventually some
version of that idea
will trickle down to the rest
of the world with the idea
that therefore you can
actually have a relatively
appropriate conversation
about the right way
to advance democracy or
secure the national interest
or what have you.
Of course there is a
valid question about
whether or not the
marketplace of ideas
actually works terribly well.
And indeed, part of the
reason I wrote this book
was that things
had been happening
over the last few
years that suggest
that maybe intellectuals
don't necessarily--
the sort of way in which the
marketplace of ideas functions
isn't exactly the way
we would want it to.
So Exhibit A would be the notion
that you had on the one hand
a president in Barack Obama
who actually, I think,
thought of himself
as an intellectual.
And yet once he
became president,
to some extent felt
imprisoned by a category
he referred to as the blob which
refer to the sort of collection
of foreign policy intellectuals
and think tankers and so
on and so forth in Washington
DC who he felt constrained
what he could do as president.
And then on the other hand,
you have Donald Trump.
And you have to give
Donald Trump credit.
As a candidate, he
managed to actually unify
the opinions of people who
studied foreign policy ranging
from the far left
to the far right,
in which there was almost
unanimity that this guy would
be an unmitigated disaster as
a foreign policy president.
Various petitions were signed.
Various statements
from historians
or political scientists or
economists or foreign policy
experts, including a lot of
Republican foreign policy
experts, warning
this was a bad idea.
If anything, Trump
as a candidate
leaned into this
basically saying,
we need to shake the rust out
of American foreign policy.
And in some ways
echoing Michael Gove
who was a British minister who
during the Brexit campaign,
even though every sort
of expert community
warned the Brexit
would not work out well
for the British
economy, Gove responded
I welcome the fact that the
experts are on the other side.
I think we need to
listen to the people.
And as a result, despite all
of these sort of warnings,
Donald Trump got
elected president.
I also, to deal
personally with the fact--
as David said, I've
written six books.
And this is the sixth one.
And I'm proud of all my books.
But I have to recognize that
without question the book
that everyone will remember
when I am long dead and gone
is a book I wrote
about zombies which
was a small textbook trying
to explain what theories
of international
relations would predict
would happen if, in
fact, the dead started
rising from the grave and
tried to feast upon the living.
Now don't get me wrong, I'm
really proud of that book.
I worked hard on it.
But it is telling that
that's the book that
captures the most amount of
attention in the public sphere.
It makes me feel a little
bit guilty at times.
But at the same
time, and this sort
of reflects a general tendency
of debate among intellectuals,
usually when intellectuals
are talking about what
is the marketplace
of ideas look like,
what's the of state
of public discourse,
they tend to be
extremely pessimistic.
And this is a trope that
has gone on, you can argue,
from the 1950s and late
1960s with Richard Hofstadter
and "Anti-intellectuals
in American Life,"
and in the '80s Russell Jacoby,
"The Last Intellectuals."
And you have a whole raft of
books over the last few years
that have basically suggested
that the state of ideas
is not what it used to be.
And indeed, the only
debate among intellectuals
seems to be when did things
start to go downhill?
For some people it was the death
that the New York intellectuals
that would write for "Dissent,"
or what have you in the 1950s.
For others, it was the death
of Bloomsbury, the group
that actually
Keynes, among others,
was a part of in
the United Kingdom
during the anti-war period.
And then others
just basically go
back to the death of
Socrates and argue that it's
been downhill since then.
And that said, I actually don't
necessarily agree with that.
In some ways, there's
never been a better time
to be an intellectual.
There is a whole variety
of conferences and venues
in which people are
perfectly willing to hear
what I have to say.
The fact that you all
would have me here
is extremely comfortable--
extremely comforting.
But the degree of hostility
among my colleagues
about concepts like
TED Talks for example
is fascinating to me.
I have my own criticism
of that format
as a way of expressing ideas.
But I also think it's somewhat
churlish of someone like me who
is paid to talk to people to
be upset that it turns out
that there's a large category
of people that want to listen
to podcasts or watch 18 minute
videos in which they are
introduced to new ideas.
So we're kind of in
a weird situation.
We know that
something seems to be
off in the marketplace of ideas.
But on the other
hand, I do wonder
if people are potentially
being overly pessimistic.
So one explanation
for all of this
is it's all social
media's fault.
The problem is that
everyone is addicted
to Twitter or Facebook or some
Google product which I'm sure
I can't name that
is at fault. And I
don't think that's the case,
because among other things
even sort of very stodgy
public intellectuals
are now on Twitter as well.
It's not like they're
neglecting these things.
And indeed in
researching the book,
I thought this might
be one of the causes.
And I was struck by
the degree to which
regardless of one's
intellectual quality,
they all do want to
be on social media.
They will tweet about it.
My explanation instead
rests on the notion
that there are two types of
intellectuals that essentially
contribute to the
marketplace of ideas
particularly in the area
of foreign policy, which
is the area that I
know the best about.
And I call these two
categories public intellectuals
and thought leaders.
Now these are terms that
are constantly used a lot
and often mean different
things to different people.
So I'll be a little
more exact in terms
of what I'm talking about.
Public intellectuals,
in some ways,
are Isaiah Berlin's foxes.
So Isaiah Berlin wrote
a great essay back
in the 1930s called "The
Hedgehog and the Fox"
where he said that there
were two kinds of thinkers.
The fox knows a little bit
about a lot and the hedgehog
knows one big thing.
So public intellectuals
work like foxes.
They know a little
bit about a lot.
And they essentially
are critics.
Public intellectuals
excel at telling you
everything that is wrong
with everyone else's idea.
And that's a good quality.
That is a quality that you want.
If you're introduced to a new
idea, you want to know well,
what do I think about this?
And certainly to
some extent, you
want to make your own judgment.
But you also want to hear
from learned scholars
presumably in terms of
what they think about it.
Thought leaders, on the
other hand, are hedgehogs.
Thought leaders
have one big idea
that they think can
explain everything.
If you throw any kind of
policy problem at this person,
they will somehow find
a way to get it back
to whatever their big idea is.
So thought leaders
are evangelists.
Thought leaders desperately
want to tell you exactly the way
the world works.
And to some extent
one of the ways
they excel is by explaining
the extant arguments about this
are wrong, I have a better idea.
Now to be very clear, I
believe that a good functioning
marketplace of ideas needs both
of these kinds of thinkers.
You need both
public intellectuals
and you need thought leaders.
And if you have them in balance,
it works relatively well.
It means that someone will come
up with a new kind of idea.
And then you have
thought leaders
that will stress test it to
within an inch of its life.
So the bad ideas presumably
eventually disappear
and the good ideas
might actually persist,
eventually become
consensus, and indeed
might trickle down either to the
public or to key policymakers.
The problem is you're
in a situation where
it's out of balance.
If you have a marketplace
of ideas where there are too
many public intellectuals and
not enough thought leaders,
essentially the barriers
to entry are too high.
Critics are too powerful.
Someone who tries to
come up with a new idea
easily get shot down.
And so as a result,
the marketplace
becomes sort of
stagnant and ossified.
It's just an oligopoly.
It's very difficult to sort of
crack this kind of marketplace.
And that's potentially
problematic.
On the other hand, a
marketplace in which
thought leaders predominate
and there aren't
a lot of public intellectuals,
the problem in this instance
is that the barriers
to exit are too high.
In essence, you have a much
more vibrant and potentially
heterogeneous
marketplace of ideas.
The problem is, is that
stupid ideas don't die.
You operate in a world where
essentially a thought leader
can come up with
an idea that might
be seductive for a whole
variety of reasons.
But if critics aren't powerful
enough, they can't kill it.
And so as a result
bad ideas will
persist and wind up potentially
getting into the mainstream.
So essentially, if I was
writing this book back
in let's say the 1960s,
I would make the argument
that the problem is, is that
public intellectuals are
too powerful and we need
more thought leaders.
But because I'm
writing this in 2017,
I'm essentially
arguing the opposite.
That, in fact,
there are three sort
of major tectonic forces
in the United States
that have stacked the deck
powerfully in favor of thought
leaders and have undercut the
sort of traditional sources
of public intellectuals.
So I'll explain what
those three are.
The first is the
erosion of trust
in authority and expertise.
So this data comes from
the Pew Research Center.
But I could have ginned up
data from Gallup or the General
Social Survey or any kind
of long-run survey stream.
And they all show
the same thing.
With the exception of the
United States military,
Americans' trust in
every major governmental
and non-governmental institution
has declined precipitously
since the 1960s.
Essentially beginning with
Vietnam and Watergate,
it follows this
exact same thing.
It goes-- and then it sort of
ping-pongs for a little bit.
After 9/11 there
is a brief spike.
Trust in institutions
really goes up after 9/11.
And since then, [EXPLOSION]
it's been really, really bad.
And we are now at sort of
ultra low levels in almost all
of these things.
This includes, by the way
knowledge institutions.
So the General
Social Survey runs
an annual question in terms of
confidence in knowledge based
institutions, or institutions
that generate knowledge--
medicine or higher
education or what
have you in the
scientific community.
In 1974, approximately
50% of Americans
placed a high degree of
trust in those institutions.
By 2012, the average had
fallen to 30% of Americans
that had placed high trust
in those institutions.
So as a result, the problem is,
is that essentially Americans
don't trust the sort of
traditional institutions
that generate presumably
knowledge or expertise.
Now the effect of this on
the marketplace of ideas
is pretty clear.
Which is essentially those
who traditionally produce
public intellectuals, which are
primarily universities or think
tanks or what have you, very
often used to have the ability
to argue from authority.
Which is say a Harvard
professor says thing x is bad.
And readers would
see that and think,
oh, well he's a
professor at Harvard,
we should totally listen to him,
even If he didn't necessarily
know what he was talking
about, by the way,
just the fact that he
was a Harvard professor.
But we are now
operating in a world
where no one cares
necessarily if you
are a tenured
professor at Harvard
or if you were a think
tank fellow at Brookings
or if you were a MacArthur
Genius Grant winner or a Nobel
Prize winner.
Those sort of appellations
don't matter nearly as much.
And so as a result, this has
lowered the barriers to entry.
Someone can make an argument
as a thought leader,
even if they lack, potentially,
the traditional accreditations.
Even though, by the
way, thought leaders
might very well have
these accreditations--
I'm not trying to say
that they're necessarily
less well-educated--
but it basically
by Americans distrusting
traditional sources
of authority, it opens
up the possibility
for new thought leaders
to enter the marketplace.
The second trend that
matters is the rise
of political polarization.
So this chart is from a
traditional political science
data set that scores basically
how Republicans and Democrats
in the House vote.
And as you can see,
the data on this
is relatively
incontrovertible which
is over the last 30 or
40 years or so, Democrats
have shifted somewhat to
the left and Republicans
have shifted way,
way, way to the right.
But this is not just limited to
the House of Representatives.
The Pew Research Center
shows data suggesting
that essentially the number
of extreme partisans,
both extreme left Democrats
and extreme right Republicans,
have doubled basically
between 1994 and 2014.
Now there's some debate
among political scientists
about whether or not
the rest of the country
is also becoming more polarized.
Some people argue that
essentially, yes, this
is the case and indeed
the data since 2000
suggests this is going on.
But other political
scientists argue
it's not so much that people
are becoming more extreme,
it's what we would call
partisan assorting, which
is to say essentially
traditional Southern
Democrats have suddenly
decided, oh, no,
we're actually Republicans.
Whereas, let's say, traditional
Rockefeller Republicans
who live in the Northeast
realized, no, we're
actually Democrats.
And so if those two
categories switch parties,
it makes it look like there's
stronger polarization when
really what's
happening is people are
finding their ideological home.
The one thing you can say is
that the political parties
are becoming more
ideologically homogeneous.
in a way that was not
true 40 years ago.
And the real problem
now is the effect
this has on political
elites in terms of how
they view the other side.
Essentially you now have
polling that essentially
shows that an ever increasing
fraction of both Republicans
and Democrats view the partisans
on the other side as a threat
to the country,
which they did not
view in terms of survey evidence
from like the 1960s or 1970s.
And that they thought they
were a threat to the nation's
well-being.
And indeed we are
now at the point
where survey evidence also
shows that extreme partisans
on both sides don't
want their children
to marry outside of their
ideological persuasion.
So essentially what is happening
is that partisanship has almost
replaced religion or
race or gender as sort
of a person's principle notion
of identity to some extent.
And indeed there was one survey
paper that basically took--
that created fake resumes of
people in which they could
potentially put something
in like someone was working
for the Young Democrats
or the Young Republicans
in college or
something, basically
a way to sort of signal
to the employer what
their ideological
predisposition was.
And then they also,
before they did this,
surveyed those
employers to find out
what their own political
predilections were.
And what turned
out is that people
who scored as either very
conservative or very liberal
were more likely
to discriminate on
hires based on political
partisanship than based
on race or religion
or sexual orientation.
So in other words, partisanship
is a powerful drug.
Now the reason this affects
the marketplace of ideas
is that essentially if you are
a public intellectual, almost
by definition, you are going
to have heterogeneous opinions.
You are sometimes going to
say something that says, hey,
you know what, I
think the left might
be somewhat wrong on issues
like public school choice.
Or I think the right
might be wrong on denying
the existence of climate change
and the need for US policy
to address it.
The problem here is that
essentially political partisans
on both sides want their
own House intellectuals.
They don't want to hear
contrarian points of view.
And so as a result,
this basically
rewards people who are
perfectly willing to say things
that essentially reinforce
partisan's preexisting
worldviews.
So someone like a Dinesh D'souza
on the right for example,
who can just say
everything is Obama's fault
or Sean Hannity would be
another example of this.
And then the final
trend that matters is
the rise of wealth inequality.
And again, the data on this is
relatively incontrovertible.
Over the last 30
to 40 years, life
has been extremely good for
the top 1% of the income
distribution.
But if life has been
good for the top 1%,
life has been super
awesome for the top 0.01%.
Now the reason this
matters in terms
of the marketplace of
ideas is not so much
the effects on society, but
rather essentially we now
have a new class of plutocrats
that essentially has more money
than they know what to do with.
And it turns out that
what they want to do
is go back to college.
They already have
a genuine interest
in promoting greater degrees
of intellectual discourse.
And this is true whether we're
talking about Mark Zuckerberg
or whether we're
talking about Bill Gates
or whether we're talking
about the Koch brothers.
Except it turns out they don't
actually go back to college.
What they wind up
doing is creating
their own intellectual
salons or attending
other intellectual salons, like
the Davos World Economic Forum
or PopTech or South by
Southwest or the Milken Global
Conference, or a whole variety
of these kinds of conference
circuits.
Now this in and of itself
is not a bad thing.
I think this, on the
whole, it's genuinely good
that billionaires have
an interest in ideas.
And certainly this
doesn't make them
any different from, let's
say, predecessors like Andrew
Carnegie or John Rockefeller.
The difference is, is that
these people are still alive.
And because they're
still alive, they
do want to use their money to
potentially try to influence
the marketplace of ideas.
But they function
in some ways like--
the term is
philanthrocapitalists,
which is essentially
they want a return
on their nonprofit investment.
They want a return on their
intellectual investment.
They want to make sure that if
they do this, it has impact.
And it's tough to measure
impact when we're talking
about the marketplace of ideas.
I mean we can measure the degree
to which things are mentioned,
but that doesn't necessarily
mean that people agree with it
or not or that people have
truly internalized the beliefs.
And this can potentially
be a problem.
It's also potentially a problem
because, essentially, you
can argue that the top
0.01%, the billionaires,
might have very strong
disagreements on things
like social policy or even
potentially economic policy.
But by hanging around
with each other
and by potentially going
to these conferences,
they wind up sharing a
similar kind of world view.
Which is they,
generally speaking,
don't necessarily
believe that much
in the role of
the state in terms
of providing key public
goods or providing
key functions in terms
of both domestic politics
and in terms of foreign policy.
And indeed, there is a
danger to some extent
that they might
look at the world
and look at
international relations
and look at sort of
traditional diplomacy
and essentially think of it
as a faulty piece of code
that either needs to
be bypassed or hacked.
Now potentially--
and so as a result,
you wind up with nonprofits that
essentially completely bypass
the state.
And there are times when that
might actually be correct.
But there are also times
where you simply cannot ignore
the role of the American
government in terms of doing
things like running
foreign policy.
So who are the
winners and losers
as a result of this kind
of new ideas industry?
The losers are sort of
the traditional sources
of authority.
So as I said
before, universities
face some difficulties.
On the one hand, the
sort of expansion
of the entire marketplace
does lead to a demand
for more intellectuals.
But it also shifts the demand
from public intellectuals
to thought leaders.
And the simple fact is, and I
can say this being a university
professor, most
university professors
are public intellectuals.
I mean we hedge ourselves to
within an inch of our lives
when we're talking to the
public because that's what we do
when we do our scholarly work.
But most members of the public
don't want to hear us hedging.
They want to hear people
making very powerful
affirmative statements saying
this is true, even if we're not
necessarily certain about this.
The other problem is,
is that universities
run afoul of at least
two of the trends
that I talked about causing a
shift to thought leaders, which
is university professors are
actually shifting way further
to the left.
So this is a chart from
the UCLA's Higher Education
Research Institute that
basically surveys professors
and asked them whether
they self-identify as being
on the left or liberal,
moderate, or being
conservative.
And as you can see from the
data, basically in 1989, 1990,
you had approximately
two liberals on campus
for every conservative.
So there's no denying
that the campuses were
always further to the left
than the American body politic,
but it wasn't that much.
We're now operating in a
world where essentially you
have six times as many
liberals as you do
conservatives in universities.
And this ratio is
even more concentrated
if you exit let's
say the hard sciences
and talk about the
social sciences.
And the problem with
this is twofold.
First, just because people in
political science departments
or economics departments
are way to the left
doesn't mean they
do bad research.
That would be like complaining
that the military is further
to the right and therefore
we can't trust them.
These are all professions.
They operate according to
professional codes and ethics.
Peer reviewed
scholarship doesn't get
accepted just because it
promotes a liberal worldview.
What it does do, however, is
potentially alter the questions
that scholars ask.
And so as a result, I do think
the conservative criticism
of universities is a
little more accurate here
in saying if conservatives
are not on campus,
then there might be
certain questions
that they don't ask
because it makes liberals
somewhat uncomfortable.
And the other issue here
is that essentially it
creates an easy cheap shot.
Which is to say if a
group of professors
produces an impeccable
piece of research
arguing we must do public policy
x and conservatives don't like
it for whatever
reason, conservatives
can always say, well,
that is a typical response
from an out of touch
elite liberal academic.
And there is at
least some degree
of truth in that statement, even
if the actual research is still
accurate.
And so as a result, it renders
them politically vulnerable.
The second group of
losers are the sort
of traditional
nonprofit think tanks.
And here I'm talking about
things like the Council
on Foreign Relations or
the Brookings Institution
or the Center for Strategic
and International Studies
or what have you.
Oh, sorry, I should go back.
There was one other
evidence of this
so I did survey elite
intellectuals and policy
makers about their attitudes
about social science,
basically asking them if they
had more or less confidence
in it over the last 10 years.
So this is the chart showing
all of the responses I got.
And if you lump together more
confidence and about the same,
you have a majority
of people that
have pretty strong faith in the
research from social science.
But this is what the
data looks like if you
look at people who
self-identified
as either conservative
or libertarian.
Which is they are much more
skeptical of academic research
than other forms
of intellectuals.
With regard to think
tanks, one of the things
that has happened
over the last 10 years
or so is that essentially the
2008 financial crisis has left
think tanks badly overexposed.
In the previous seven years
between 9/11 and 2008,
a lot of think tanks
suddenly started
building gawdy new
headquarters in Washington.
They got a lot of
research funding
from the federal government.
Their endowments were swelling
because the stock market
was booming and so forth.
Then when the crash happened,
federal funding dried up
and traditional sort of
foundation support dried up.
So as a result, these
think tanks wound up
trying to look for
new sources of income.
In some cases, it
was Silicon Valley.
In other cases, it was
traditional multinational
corporations.
In other cases, it was
foreign governments.
And the problem is
that this has left
think tanks being exposed to
essentially accusations of pay
for play.
There's actually a memo from
the government of Norway
arguing that we should totally
fund think tanks in Washington,
because that's how we can
access key policymakers.
And accusations of
conflict of interest
are extremely difficult to
combat for nonprofit think
tanks.
And in terms of
political science,
as opposed to economics,
this is another issue.
Essentially one of the
arguments I make in the book
is that economics
has done really
well in this new marketplace.
Whereas my traditional
discipline, political science,
has not.
There are a variety
of reasons for this.
But the biggest
one I would argue
is that economists
are simultaneously
more to the right than
political scientists are.
If you poll economists,
they're much more
closer to the political center.
And also economists
have a world view
that sells extremely
well to plutocrats.
Which is to say the logic
of the invisible hand,
the logic of if just engage in
the pursuit of self-interest,
all of society
benefits, is a message
that billionaires like to hear.
Political scientists,
on the other hand,
we're just the
skunks at the party.
We like to tell people
that essentially there
are structural factors
that really matter.
That individual agency is not
necessarily that important.
And if you're
really, really rich,
this is partially
due to your effort,
but it might be
partially due to the fact
that you were born
on third base.
And that is something
that, surprisingly,
a lot of rich people
don't like to hear.
So they won't listen
to political scientists
necessarily, but they certainly
will listen to economists.
All right.
In terms of the winners,
there are three categories.
The first is the private
sector supplier of ideas--
and I'll get to that
in a little bit.
The second are sort of the
more partisan think tanks.
And Beyonce always wins.
Let's just be honest about that.
But the reason I have Beyonce
there is basically I'm
talking about
intellectual superstars.
So in terms of the
McKinsey's of the world,
what you're increasingly
seeing is the rise
of for-profit think tanks.
Whether we're talking
about the McKinsey Global
Institute or Goldman Sachs
Research Institute or Kohlberg
Kravis and Roberts,
which actually hired
David Petraeus to head their
own in-house think tank,
or political risk consulting
like the Eurasia Group,
these kinds of groups genuinely
produce interesting research.
I've consumed a
lot of their work.
And I generally-- I don't
mean to diminish it--
but there are two
potential problems with it.
The first is, is
that because these
are for-profit industries,
they very often don't make
their data available to people.
Because very often, if
McKinsey Global Institute
is producing a
report, the report
is based in no small part
on the proprietary work
they have done by consulting
for various corporations.
So they can
legitimately explain we
can't make this data available.
Which is fine, but it
makes it hard for me
as an outsider to necessarily
take their arguments on faith--
or it requires me to take
their arguments on faith.
I can't stress test
their own analysis.
And this is certainly
true as well even
within the confines
of Silicon Valley
when Facebook does an
analysis on social, media,
for example or
something like that.
The second problem with
this is that weirdly
even though for-profit companies
obviously are generally
producing this research with the
idea of attracting and drawing
people in to hire
their services,
weirdly that is seen
as less hypocritical
than nonprofit think
tanks doing research.
Because at least the for-profit
folks like McKinsey are saying
look we're out to make a buck.
And weirdly enough, in the
marketplace of ideas that
is somehow seen as refreshing.
The second group of winners are
the more partisan think tanks.
And here the Heritage Foundation
is a good example on the right.
The Center for American Progress
as an example on the left.
And the reason is that you
increasingly have people
either in the form of
Sheldon Adelson on the right
or let's say Tom Steyer on
the left that are perfectly
willing to fund partisan
think tanks but actually don't
want these think tanks
to necessarily cooperate
with people on the other
side to actually produce
let's say cross-cutting policy
issues like prison reform
or promoting human rights
and American foreign policy.
And then in terms of superstars,
we can talk about the fact
that essentially one of the
things that has happened now,
even in the marketplace
for foreign policy ideas,
is that it
increasingly resembles
the marketplace for either
entertainment or sports.
Which is essentially the
people at the very top tier
wind up commanding a
disproportionate share
of the total revenue
from that sector.
And so as a result, you have
people like Fareed Zakaria, who
is sort of a traditional
public intellectual,
and Niall Ferguson, who
is just down the road,
and I would argue is
a traditional thought
leader commanding anywhere
between mid-five figures
to low six figures for
speaking fees which they
can do once or twice a month.
Now, again, for many of you
potentially and certainly
for many of the people
in this headquarters,
the idea of potentially
making a million dollars
by just giving
speeches for a year
might not seem like
that much money.
To someone like me who got
a PhD in political science
and never imagined
that that would ever
be within the realm
possibility, this
does affect what
you do somewhat.
And as a result, if you can
make it to that top tier,
if you can make it to that
sort of top speaking level,
you wind up actually
becoming a superstar.
But the other problem
is that you wind up
essentially becoming
a brand rather
than an individual thinker.
Essentially you
are no longer asked
to just write a column for
the "Washington Post," which
Fareed Zakaria does, you
have to write a column.
You have to produce a book.
You have to do a TV show.
You do a TV documentary
based on the book you wrote,
which by the way Niall
Ferguson has done six times.
All of these things
are really good.
But essentially, you
are asking intellectuals
to do the one thing
that intellectuals
are really, really bad at
which is manage themselves.
And inevitably, if you wind up
being put in this situation,
corners don't
necessarily get cut
but they get rounded
a little bit.
So in the case of
Fareed Zakaria,
he has run into trouble in
terms of plagiarism scandals
because it turns out that
approximately 15 of his columns
cribbed language
from other things.
He had basically cut and paste.
Or in the case of
Niall Ferguson,
making claims in his
columns he just turned out
to be wildly
factually inaccurate.
And the problem is that
this sort of intellectuals
in the top tier wind up making
ever more of these mistakes.
And as a result, the sort
of top tier intellectuals,
particularly thought
leaders, wind up
essentially being treated a
lot like indie rock bands which
is everyone who likes
their early work,
their early authentic
work back when
they were sort of tat the
low level, when it just
used to be about the ideas man.
But then, once they actually
get to a degree of celebrity,
they wind up producing
things that invite
massive amounts of criticism.
And the result is
that, therefore,
a world in which the
marketplace of ideas
now functions in some ways
like financial markets.
Which is to say there
are asset bubbles.
There are ideas that gain a fair
amount of intellectual cachet
that might actually have
some germs of a really
good argument.
But as a result, wind up
getting applied more and more
to sectors that they never
should have been applied to.
And one example of
this is the logic
of disruptive innovation,
which is certainly
embraced within Silicon Valley.
And I think you could
argue potentially even
applies to Silicon
Valley, but does not
apply to things
like foreign policy
or higher education or other
sectors of the economy, which
Clayton Christensen who
came up with this idea
claimed that it actually did.
And so as a result, these
ideas expand far more
than they used to because
thought leaders have more power
than they used to.
And it takes more effort
by public intellectuals
to beat it back.
The other effect of this
on particularly successful
intellectuals is that
because they will potentially
produce less quality work once
they get up to the top tier,
and because they are commanding
a disproportionate share
of the benefit, they
essentially become targets
with huge Xes on their backs.
Which means the effect of
this on those intellectuals
is that they are going
to be more and more
likely to tune out criticism.
Because to be fair,
this criticism
will often come in the form
of trolling or take downs.
You know, I've talked to
Fareed Zakaria about this.
And he says that about 2/3 of
the criticism he gets, because
of columns that he writes
for the "Washington Post"
or because of his show on CNN
is essentially racist in origin
that accuse him of being
like a member of ISIS
or accuse him of
some absurd thing.
And he can legitimately
and appropriately should
dismiss that.
The problem becomes
is that if you
do that, it's a slippery
slope to start to dismiss
almost all forms of criticism.
Because you can dismiss
those who criticize you
as either trolls or
partisan hacks or people who
are not as well-read as you.
And it becomes to the
point where you just
wind up going in your
own cocoon and not
being receptive to any
kind of advice whatsoever.
And the result is what
I call the Dark Knight
Theory of the ideas
industry, which is you
either die in obscurity
or you live long enough
to see yourself
become everything
that you despised when you
became a young intellectual.
And there are degrees to
which I feel like even--
I'm not at the Niall Ferguson
or Fareed Zakaria level.
I like to think
of myself as sort
of upper middle class in terms
of the public intellectual
world.
And yet there are times
where I look at myself,
it's like dude,
what are you doing?
And you know I do
get worried about it.
So what is to be done?
And I confess that
here the problem
is, is that the sort of
trends that I'm talking about,
which is the erosion of trust,
rise of political polarization,
increase in wealth inequality,
are kind of macro trends
that require major
large scale reforms.
And whether or not they affect
the marketplace of ideas
or not is almost a
subsidiary question.
But given that those trends
are going to persist,
what can be done?
One thing I would argue
is that universities
need to do a better job in
terms of promoting not just
individual academics, but
also promoting their brands.
So one of the things I did
as being part of the Fletcher
School was we took a
Carnegie Corporation grant
about trying to make
better connections in terms
of our research to policymakers.
And we went out as
a combined team.
So it wasn't just me, it was
me and like five other Fletcher
School researchers.
And while I know
that teamwork is
more common in
the hard sciences,
in the social sciences,
it's a little rarer.
And the thing I was
struck by doing this
was the degree to which
people in the US government
or people in the European
Union or even public audiences
seemed more impressed that
we were all part of Fletcher
rather than sort of our
own individual names.
And in some ways, for them I
think the whole was greater
than the sum of the parts.
The second thing that needs
to be done is just patience.
Which is to say, I do think
that one of the things that's
been happening in the
philanthropic world that
has been unfortunate has been
this obsession with impact.
The notion that if you give
money to university professors
or think tanks, you want
to see an immediate payoff
as a result of that.
And the truth is,
is that very often
in the marketplace of ideas,
you need to have patience.
You need to recognize
that if you fund research,
it's not always going
to come immediately.
And furthermore, even
if you write a book
that no one
immediately listens to,
it might actually potentially
become more influential three,
four, or five years from now.
And so that's not nothing.
The middle one is more
foundation support
essentially for more
traditional public intellectuals
to learn how to better gain
the marketplace of ideas.
How better to actually
go in and make
their own particular points.
And then the last thing
is self-restraint.
In some ways, intellectuals,
you would argue,
are potentially the one category
of individual that presumably
doesn't only care about
money, that we do actually
are supposed to care about
the quality of our ideas.
And so I would like to
think that over time what
might eventually happen is that
even people like Fareed Zakaria
or Niall Ferguson
do care desperately
what other intellectuals
think of them.
And so potentially
being told maybe
you don't have to say
yes to every speaking gig
or say yes to every book
contract would potentially
allow something in the way
of more diversity at the top
of the intellectual food chain.
And with that I'm happy
to take your questions.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that--
you talked about disruption
in higher education.
How do you reconcile
that with the cost
of student debt, increasing
costs of education going up?
DANIEL DREZNER: I would
say two things on that.
The first is, is
that while I don't
deny the increase in
student debt overall,
a disturbingly large
portion of that
is not actually from
what you would consider
traditional universities.
It's mostly coming from the
private, for-profit university
sector.
And that's a real problem.
But I would divorce, let's
say the University of Phoenix
or some of these other
for-profit universities
from what you would think
of traditionally as the sort
of four year colleges.
If you actually take a
look at the average debt
load of people who go
to those institutions,
I believe it's around
$30,000, which is--
I don't want to
dismiss that entirely,
but if you have a
debt load of $30,000
after graduating with
a BA, you are probably
going to be able to get a
job that can pay that off.
So I think, among
other things, claims
that there is a
higher ed bubble have
been by and large exaggerated.
That said, I will say this.
And this is going to be
something where I'm actually
going be looking at this
over the next couple of years
and I'll be curious.
You can argue that one of the
ways in which universities have
been able to fund themselves
over the last 10 years or so
has been an increase in the
number of foreign students
studying in the United States.
And that's been a
definite increase.
There was a lull after 9/11,
but basically over the last 10
years to 15 years, you've seen
increases on the order of 5%-6%
a year.
There is increasing evidence
that that is coming to an end.
Now part of that was because
the dollar has risen in value.
So suddenly we're
just more expensive
regardless of tuition prices.
But there is no denying the fact
that Donald Trump as president
has potentially cast something
of a pall on foreign students
potentially trying to
apply to the United States.
There was an
interesting OECD paper
called "The War on Talent" that
talked about how essentially--
or "The Global
Market for Talent"
that there are essentially
four places where
well-educated individuals
go to get jobs--
the United States, the United
Kingdom, Canada, and Australia.
It would be interesting to see
over the next couple of years
whether, because of Brexit
and because of the Trump
administration, you see high
levels of human capital flows
decline in both the United
States the United Kingdom
and increase to places
like Canada or Australia.
And if that happens,
then it'll be
interesting to see
what happens in terms
of the economics of
higher education.
AUDIENCE: In terms
of over the past 20,
30 years and the
accessibility of information,
how do you think that
impacts the kind of scale--
DANIEL DREZNER: No,
that's a great question.
I think that's part of
the source of it, which
is if you are genuinely
interested in something--
it used to be well you
have to go to school
in order to figure out how do
I find out the information.
You now literally can
Google it, potentially.
So I think on the one
hand, that's a good thing.
It means that
potentially people who
are genuinely
interested in ideas
don't need a Stanford
degree or a Harvard degree
or any degree to be
able to potentially read
what they want to read.
The problem with it is
that essentially you
are seeing increasingly a
degree of cyberbalkanization
in which whatever your
sort of preexisting
intellectual worldview
is, you are naturally
going to be drawn to that
quarter of the internet
to get information that
seems to be confirming it.
And indeed, this
is actually a case
where potentially education
doesn't necessarily
play that much role.
Indeed well-educated
people are often better
at cocooning themselves than
less well-educated people.
Because well-educated
people can rationalize why
they're cocooning in a way
that less well-educated people
can't.
That said, I don't
want to say that this
is like an overwhelming
phenomenon.
Not everyone cocoons themselves.
There's a reason why
things like TED Talks
are particularly popular.
There's a reason why you see
an ever increasing number
of platforms for people who
can potentially try to make
these kinds of arguments.
I would argue there are a
fair number of Americans
that genuinely either
don't have really
strong ideological priors or
are intellectually rigorous
enough to recognize
look I might be wrong so
what is the best contrary view.
And in that sense, that's
good for people like me.
Because it means we have a
wider audience than we used to.
I remember being told
once when I was first
getting my PhD that if I wanted
to influence policy makers,
there were basically four
places I could publish--
the Op-Ed page in the "New York
Times," the "Washington Post,"
the "Wall Street Journal,"
and "Foreign Affairs."
that that was what
like policymakers
read and it didn't matter
what the public cared about.
That's obviously changed.
And one of the
benefits of that is
that there are now different
ways that you can potentially
influence top policy makers.
It's not just talking
to them in a room,
it's also if you
make an argument that
is seen as relatively
popular that it attracts
enough eyeballs to
reading it, it generates
more attention that way.
And we're in a situation now
where you can write something
for "Medium" and it goes viral
in a way that even if you write
something for "Foreign Affairs"
and the "New York Times"
it doesn't.
So it's a mixed bag.
Hopefully, as I
said at the outset,
there's a tendency when
you write about this stuff
to think, oh, god, things
were so much better before.
I don't want to
make that argument.
I don't think things
are great, but I
think they're just bad in a
different way from the way they
were before.
AUDIENCE: As a
consumer of ideas,
my strategy for avoiding
any cocooned or you know
stuck in some place is
to look for moderates.
Look for moderates who I
think are very intelligent.
And so Niall Ferguson is
a good example for me.
If I pick "New York
Times," I would
pick David Brooks for example.
But I mean does that seem
like a reasonable approach.
DANIEL DREZNER:
No, you're stupid
and you shouldn't do
that-- no I'm joking.
But I would actually--
I would dispute-- let
me put it this way,
I would push back somewhat.
Which is to say I don't want
a world where all you're doing
is listening to moderates.
First of all the word
moderate doesn't--
I can paint two different
kinds of moderates
that would have extremely
different kinds of views.
Part of the issue
is that talking
about the left-right political
spectrum works in some ways,
but it doesn't work in others.
But the other thing is
that very often someone
working on the far right or
even working on the far left
does come up with a genuinely
interesting idea that
has to become--
that you should be exposed to.
So I got to spend three weeks
in Bellagio Italy, for example--
I'll explain why this
story is coming up--
at the Rockefeller Foundation.
They have a villa
in Bellagio, Italy.
I highly recommend
this for everyone.
Everyone should spend
three weeks in Bellagio.
It's a great thing to do.
But one of the things
I did while I was there
is that I decided not to
use Twitter or social media
as a general rule.
The reason this matters
is that for me Twitter
is kind of my news feed.
And I follow a variety of
people intellectually pretty
heterogeneous.
And what I discovered
over those three weeks
was that essentially rather
than sort of having a fire alarm
style of exposure to ideas
where I would just have the feed
and I would just get constantly
bombarded with new ideas,
I actually had to do
actively searching.
It was more police patrolling.
I had to actually
go look for things.
And I was able to find them
the moderate centrist ideas
that I found potentially
naturally appealing.
What was more difficult was to
find the more contrarian takes
on both the left and the
right, because that required
me to go to sites where
the wheat to chaff ratio
was so low that I didn't want
to read like 10 bad articles
to find one good one.
Whereas on the other
hand, weirdly social media
let me-- like it meant that
others would read those things
and say, hey, this is good
you should check this out.
And because I trusted that
person, I would then read it.
And it's not like I would
always agree with it,
but it was an interesting
provocative argument.
And so weirdly, I think,
by being off social media,
I actually found myself lacking
those kinds of contrarian
takes which are the
ones that I value
because those are the
ones that challenge
my preconceived worldviews.
And doesn't mean
they convince me,
but at least it makes
me have to figure out
what do I agree with,
why does this trouble me
so much and so forth.
So I would say you don't
want to just listen
to people like Niall
Ferguson or David Brooks,
you want to read Paul
Krugman, or you want
to read "Jacobin" magazine.
You're not always
going to agree with it,
and you probably will
very rarely will,
but you might get exposed to
a different point of view.
AUDIENCE: Are there any
public intellectuals right
now that you admire
for not succumbing
to the sort of self-promotion,
who are willing to be obscure?
DANIEL DREZNER: Oh, wow.
No one's asked me that.
Actually a guy that
I genuinely admire
is Francis Fukuyama which might
sound odd because everyone--
the one thing I'm sure you've
heard if you say Francis
Fukuyama is "End of History."
Like well that was totally
wrong and why should you
listen to him?
Fukuyama really, I
think, in some ways
could have become an even
bigger superstar if he chose to.
He could have on
the TED Talk route
or gotten a column or
so on and so forth.
He has stuck instead
to writing books.
First of all, I would argue
"The End of History" book
if you actually read it as a
much more nuanced discussion
than the sort of
caricature version of it.
But the other thing is that he's
really done some excellent work
since then.
And It's not that he's
like JD Salinger in Vermont
not doing anything new or
not engaging the public.
He does.
It's just that he does it
in a very judicious way.
And in some ways I admire
his self-control on that.
I don't have necessarily
have that option, as I said,
I'm not quite at that level.
But he's definitely someone
who I admire in terms
of being able to do that.
I guess the other person I would
admire would be Samantha Power.
Not that I necessarily agree
with her on everything.
But she wrote a great book
"A Problem From Hell,"
wound up being an adviser to
the Obama campaign in 2008,
and then eventually
became the UN ambassador.
The reason I admire her is
first because she's extremely,
passionate about her ideas.
But far more
important than that,
I did a very depressing
survey of asking
people who they thought the most
influential intellectuals were
in the foreign policy world.
And of the top 25 names,
there was one woman.
And it was her.
And that was just
really depressing
because I know a fair
number of really smart women
who have serious impact.
But the fact that
that was the answer,
I found profoundly disturbing.
And so one of the other ways,
which I didn't talk about,
that I do think you can improve
the marketplace of ideas
is by promoting a greater
degree of diversity.
Not necessarily because
women are automatically
going to have better ideas than
men or even different ideas
from men but it does break
up that sort of superstar
concentration that
I don't think is
good for the
marketplace of ideas.
MODERATOR: All right.
Well I think that's
it for questions.
Thank you everyone for coming.
And let's give a hand to
Mr. Drezner one last time.
DANIEL DREZNER:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]